good afternoon my name is Matthew
Spalding I'm associate vice president
and Dean for Hillsdale College here in
Washington DC welcome to the Allen Pete
Kirby Center for Constitutional studies
and citizenship for those of you who
have been keeping score lately there are
a number of important tallies yesterday
mostly predictable fortunately the Nats
held on to their series for one the
Redskins predictably lost to the
Seahawks 21 17 and marriage lost in the
Supreme Court by at least 6 to 3 in
which they voted to deny assert to
several cases coming up in five states
based on a previous very confusing
decision last year by this Court
they will probably play out in six more
states in which they tacitly endorsed a
new definition of marriage never before
have so many been so confused by so few
and so we blithely go on in this new
brave new world it's times like this
when it's been very important that we
look back to our roots recur to the
first principles of politics but also
humanity we call that broad sweep of
freedom the flourishing of human freedom
the blessings of liberty as it says in
our Constitution the union of virtue and
happiness that exists in the very
economy and course of nature as
Washington's first inaugural and to give
you a sense this grand sweep to recall
those ideas I can think of no better
person than today's speaker a good
friend of mine as is our tradition here
at Hillsdale College he will be
introduced by a current student Christie
Berg she is a junior from Shelby
Township Michigan
she's a history major at Hillsdale
College she is currently here in
Washington C with the Washington
Hillsdale internship program and
interning for the world war 1 Centennial
Commission
Thank You dr. Spaulding it is an honor
to be introducing our guest speaker
today the author of several books
including the new road to serfdom and
inventing freedom how the
english-speaking peoples made the modern
world Daniel Hannan studied modern
history at Marlborough Berle College and
Oriel College Oxford first elected to
the European Parliament in 1999 he
represents South East England as a
member of the Conservative Party
additionally he serves as the
secretary-general of the Alliance of
European conservatives and reformists
mr. Hannen contributes frequently to
several newspapers including The Wall
Street Journal and The Daily Telegraph
he is perhaps most famous for his speech
before Parliament where he called former
Prime Minister Gordon Brown the quote
devalued prime minister of a devalued
government if you haven't seen the clip
I recommend watching it on YouTube
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming mr. Daniel Hannan
well thank you very much for your kind
words thank you for having me here in
this beautiful room in this wonderful
facility
Hillsdale is such a success story the
way in which it develops this massive
foothold here in the capital an academic
institution has become such a powerful
part of the national conversation and a
function that is reflected in our
glorious surroundings I was talking to
Matthew who is an old friend of mine
about the room that we're in and his
intention of making it a room that would
be beautiful rather than just a room
that looked like a lecture theatre
beauty is truth truth beauty says the
poet Keats and how very true in fact you
know I think this is true really in
large part of this city it's much nicer
in practice than in theory before you
come to Washington DC it's a sort of
shorthand isn't it for all the things we
don't like big remote unaccountable
government that's become cut off from
the people it's supposed to serve and
yet if you worked where I work in the
European Parliament in Brussels you
would come here and you would breathe a
deep sigh of satisfaction at the
classicism at the human scale at the
harmonious proportion this was again
beauty is truth truth beauty there are
fine buildings here that were built to
express a glorious and transcendent
truth about the relationship between
government and people and one of my
favorite buildings is the National
Archives and of course it contains next
to the Declaration of Independence and
the Constitution signing we see
represented on the picture over there it
contains a copy of Magna Carta and I
wanted to talk a little bit because of
the coming anniversary 800th centenary
of the Great Charter comes in June maybe
the way of beginning recalling the
importance of that document is to take
you back
800 years but to August 1647 London was
a tense and frightened City the English
Civil War had just ended in victory
thank heaven for supporters of
parliamentary supremacy over supporters
of royal absolutism but it was already
becoming clear that the real power in
the land rested with the Puritan
troopers of the New Model Army who were
advancing on the capital angry and
unpaid and in a gesture of conciliation
to the soldiery Parliament appointed
their commander Sir Thomas Fairfax as
constable of the Tower of London and the
first act of the great round head
general on taking up that office was an
encouraging one he called for the
greatest treasure in the tower to be
brought before him not a crown or a
scepter or a casket of gems but an old
desiccated parchment covered with
spidery and barely legible latin script
and as he lifted the copy of Magna Carta
Fairfax breathed reverentially this is
that we have fought for and by God's
help we must maintain now why am i
coming all the way to Washington DC to
talk about this 800 year old Charter
well part of the reason is that
curiously it's always I think mattered
rather more on this side of the Atlantic
than in the place where it was sealed
the act of sealing took place in my own
electoral district on the riverbank at
Runnymede and the place where that
extraordinary event that that event of
planetary significance took place went
completely unmarked until 1957 when a
memorial stone was finally raised there
by
the American Bar Association remained to
this day the only monument to the
birthplace of freedom I'm actually
working on getting another monument
raised there by June of next year and if
anybody would like to be involved with
that please come and talk to me
afterwards they say the definition of
chutzpah is you know pleading for mercy
as an often are after you've been found
guilty of parasite but actually the real
definition of trust for us to come to it
and then plug a different cause but I
think it's so in keeping with with the
values of Hillsdale and particularly
those of dr. Spaulding who's originally
these wonderful books that it's okay to
mention it here you know there was a
lovely episode two years ago when the
Prime Minister of the UK David Cameron
was here always was in New York and he
was being interviewed on the Letterman
Show and he was asked what does Magna
Carta mean literally what do the words
mean and he didn't know or at least he
pretended that he didn't know I suspect
he did know really David Cameron was at
the most prestigious private school in
the UK for five years doing compulsory
Latin I find it hard to believe that he
actually at that said Winston Churchill
did once famously translate a piece of
Latin in the House of Commons into
English as he put it for the benefit of
any at onehans who might be present so
maybe David Cameron himself an old
Etonian would have been in me but I I
kind of think I mean Magna right it's a
it's the it's the first it's the first
declension adjective in Carter coming
you can infer that one from context
can't you I might my private theory
about this is that David Cameron was
humming hamming up the role of a kind of
Hugh Grant British prime minister the
kind of you know hapless whose we like
to think that you like that sort of
thing but whether or not that was the
case the fascinating of course his
audience did have far greater
familiarity with the precepts and
principles of the charter than a British
audience would have had because the this
continent began to be seeded from the
old world when the mania for Magna Carta
was at its height during the the 17th
century
and this it was seen as the ultimate
guarantor of our freedom it's been cited
more than a hundred times by your
supreme court you're in the 1930s a
great opponent of Roosevelt's New Deal
that Texan jurist Hatton Sun was
speaking to a group of lawyers referring
to the Declaration of Independence and
the Constitution said a straight road
runs from Runnymede to Philadelphia he
said we didn't inherit our rights we won
them on the battlefield
they're a part of the collective
American folk right what was so special
about it I mean you know there is an
awful lot of cynicism even now it was a
deal made by a cornered king and his
mutinous Nobles why 800 years on am i
coming over to Washington DC to talk
about it well there is a there's a copy
of the Charter now I think in New York
is just left Boston it's doing a tour
and I can tell you that the crowds
coming to see it don't need convincing
there are four original copies of Magna
Carta contemporaneous ones that were
sealed at the field in Runnymede two of
them are in cathedrals one at Lincoln
and one at Salisbury tended like the
relics that were removed at the time of
the Reformation the other two were in
the British Library did you know what
you can go and look at them and there
isn't a particular fuss there's no line
to get in there's no security I do I
took my children right up to the ones
the one at Lincoln Cathedral one sleepy
old guide no big deal when that same
copy was exhibited in New York at the
World Exhibition in 1939 an almost
unbelievable 14 and a half million
people crushed in to see it the war
broke out while it was still on display
and it was transferred to Fort Knox for
safekeeping until the victory the app
just imaginable symbol of what the
english-speaking people's were fighting
for namely a system that elevates the
individual above the state rather than
the reverse a system that elevates the
law above the executive rather than the
reverse and here's the extraordinary
thing 800 years on because we are so
familiar with that concept the idea of
the rule of law of legal supremacy we no
longer can imagine without a great
wrench of our minds what a radical idea
it must have seemed when it was first
put forward if this extraordinary
anomalous beautiful idea that above the
government was something bigger above
the king above the holy scriptures there
was something invisible something
intangible inaudible but more powerful
than any of us something that bound the
king as surely as it bound his meanest
subject and that something was the law
the American Bar Association monument
has on the pillar the sparest purest
simplest words and they say it all to
commemorate Magna Carta symbol of
freedom under law what an extraordinary
thing and it didn't happen anywhere else
and that charter that ideal that the law
was above the state that the government
doesn't get to change the rules as it
goes along that eminent in the people is
this folk right this inheritance of
legal supremacy that contained the seeds
contained the germs of all the freedoms
that we now take for granted regular
elections and uncensored newspapers and
habeas corpus equality between men and
women jury trials all of these things
were contained in embryonic form in the
ideal of the rule of law the easiest
thing is to become blasé
about the familiar to take for granted
the ideals with which we've grown up the
heresy of our age is to think that
everyone is going to get there
eventually you know that when any
country becomes wealthy enough and
educated enough it will stumble upon the
same liberal democratic model I have to
tell you my friends history tells us a
very different story
all those ideals were overwhelmingly
developed in the language in which you
are listening to these words and
although they had their birth on that
riverbank in my constituency eight
hundred years ago they reached their
highest and most sublime form in the old
courthouse in Philadelphia that is our
shared heritage that's the patrimony
that all of us have as citizens of
common law english-speaking countries
wherever our grandparents were born
that's the link that binds us together
to see how exceptional it is see how
unusual imagine that any of the great
global conflagrations of the last
hundred years had ended differently
imagined that the first or second world
wars all that the Cold War had gone the
other way would we then be talking about
these things as universal human rights
or even Western values if we're brutally
honest
they became universal values because of
a series of military victories by the
english-speaking peoples had our fathers
yours and mine not been prepared to
deploy proportionate force in defense of
those values the world would be a very
different looking place today take you
back to a different August August 1941
the day that the Franklin D Roosevelt
made the longest walk of his presidency
up until then in a way that is literally
unimaginable today
the media had contrived to hide the fact
of the president's polio from the
electorate photographs always showed FDR
seated or standing unaided but on that
occasion invited by Winston Churchill to
join him on the decks of HMS Prince of
Wales of Newfoundland FDR was determined
literally to rise to the occasion to the
horror of his advisors who were worried
that the deck would back and that the
president would be left in an
undignified heap band struck up the
Stars and Stripes forever
and Roosevelt leaning heavily on his
cane supported on one side by his son
supported on the other by a naval
officer made his slow way across the
decks and what happened next was the
most extraordinary demonstration of what
bound the great english-speaking powers
together it happened to be a Sunday
morning and the crews of the two vessels
were paraded for a joint religious
service the sailors from the USS Augusta
which had carried Roosevelt and those of
HMS Prince of Wales Churchill had
planned every detail personally and
meticulously down to the hills down to
the reading that the chaplain gave from
the pulpit I came from Joshua one as I
was with Moses so will I be with thee I
will not fail thee nor forsake thee be
strong and of good courage and
afterwards exultant Lee Churchill burst
out to an aide the same language the
same hymns the same ideals when he said
the same ideals he wasn't making some
bland generalization that we were the
good guys think of the world as it stood
in August 1941 where else did you find
freedom under the law as that
inscription on the magna carta memorial
puts it outside the community of free
english-speaking nations the andö sphere
the whole of the Eurasian landmass
from Seoul and flatter vostok to breasts
and Lisbon was under one form or another
of dictatorship and you didn't even have
the consolation of thinking that it was
that way because of a series of military
conquests by fascists or communist
governments right yes there were some
countries where parliamentary rule had
been overthrown by invading soldiers but
there was a much longer list of
countries which hadn't needed to be
invaded in order to turn to
authoritarianism on their own it was
seen in the thirties as the coming thing
listen to the way the fascists and
communists used to speak about our
system of values look at the adjective
they always appended to it it was rotten
anglo-saxon capitalism it was decadent
anglo-american liberalism right the idea
was that it was bound to be on his way
out because how could a system that
elevated the individual that elevated
privacy and property possibly defeat one
which elevated martial glory and
collective endeavor and the sacrifice of
the individual to the many it stood to
reason that state-run militaristic
systems must be more powerful than ours
of course as we know thank God that
wasn't how it worked out
Anglo's fear freedom became the dominant
force of the post-war era and although
few countries exactly lived up to it
they all had to at least go along with
the outward forms go even to the
nastiest dictatorship today and you will
generally find something called a
congress who's nervous
delegates fingering their collars form
themselves into things called political
parties trying to anticipate the wishes
of the despot in even the most ugly
autocracies you will generally find
something called a Supreme Court which
on paper is not just an expression of
the will of the tyrant and we've won in
that sense the overall battle everyone
has to pay lip service to it but we're a
very long way away from actualizing
ideals get back
Matthews very kind in asking me to talk
about how it was that these things came
about of which I've written a book about
and it was really based on his book with
them we still hold these truths I'm
gonna give you a very short version
because it was a really fascinating
question how is it that these things
that we now take for granted these
freedoms this legal norm came about in
one language among one people and then
succeeded against all the odds and I
when I was writing the book I thought
I'll approach this like an
anthropologist go back to the time when
what we now recognize as Anglos fear
exceptionalism was becoming generalized
through the english-speaking world when
the values of personal freedom and
individualism were becoming recognized
and when indeed the english-speaking
world was beginning its takeoff from the
end of the 17th century particularly the
18th and early 19th centuries what
struck foreign visitors as unusual about
english-speaking societies maybe there's
a clue there and there were lots of them
all of you know that Tocqueville wrote
books about American democracy is much
less well known that he also wrote books
about British democracy he was married
to an Englishman he spent a lot of time
in the UK and although Tocqueville is
widely quoted especially at conservative
audiences like this he is evidently not
so widely read because although he's
quoted as the supreme witness to
American exceptionalism he makes very
plain on page one of democracy in
America that he sees the
english-speaking world as a political
continuum he talks about how in the new
world the characteristics of the old
world countries were exaggerated so
Spanish America as he saw it
exaggerated the ramshackle corruption of
Phillips Spain French America the
obscurantist senior realism of Louise
France but English America is you
was called it that he believed took
further the what we would now call
libertarian the individualist philosophy
of the mother country he had a lovely
phrase he said the American is the
Englishman left to himself and he then
went on to write about how much wider
the channel was than the Atlantic in
terms of culture he was one such visited
you know Montesquieu visited and
Voltaire and then many many more who
were less well known but who kept travel
journals who wrote letters home what
struck them as peculiar as unique about
english-speaking so were there lots of
things they found us a very
undifferentiated
aristocrats they were upset not to be
given what they thought was their due in
terms of respect they found us related
to it a very materialistic people they
were often very rude about this they
found us very money-grubbing very
lacking in higher spiritual values the
three things that I think really did
jump out in almost all of them
recognized these as being particular
isms of the english-speaking world the
first and this was really extraordinary
in its time is religious pluralism not
just religious toleration that existed
in lots of places the Ottoman Empire had
religious toleration but the freedom for
every sect to proselytize a market among
different congregations that was
absolutely unique of course happened
here first it was it was something that
came right from the moment of the
foundation of the Republic but it had
become generalized throughout the
english-speaking world the last
Emancipation sort of the final lifting
of the last few relatively mild
restrictions on non Anglicans were
lifted in the 1830s well the Spanish
Inquisition was still in force I mean it
was it was a quite extraordinary thing
and what this meant is that you could be
a free thinker without being against the
system
French Catholic writers particularly
were fascinated by this and they said it
creates a culture which then becomes
separate from what church you go to
so Tocqueville again had chapters about
how Catholics in the english-speaking
world were very libertarian and
Protestants in the in France were much
more status he said it isn't to do with
the teachings of the church it's to do
with the culture in which the
congregations can compete the second
thing which they all noticed in fact you
notice it much more as a as a traveler
than loser in native you can't really
reach Anglo sphere countries except over
water with the partial exception I'll
come back to this in a second with a
partial exception of North America the
Anglo sphere is an extended archipelago
Great Britain Ireland Australia New
Zealand Hong Kong Singapore it is true
that North America is a continent but
geopolitically it is the most isolated
or was the most isolated of all look at
Jefferson's inaugural address kindly
separated by an ocean from the
exterminating havoc of one quarter of
the globe this was the mentality of an
island people who didn't need
continental employments or listen to the
words of Washington's farewell address
still reverentially read out in the
Senate why does that matter
islands don't need a standing army in
peacetime defense is the business of the
Navy or of a territorial militia and
neither a Navy nor a militia can be used
as an instrument of internal repression
so when the government wants something
from the population it has to ask nicely
by summoning people's representatives in
a parliament and dealing with them as
taxpayers a hugely significant Adam
Smith brilliant economist was brought up
in Scotland shortly after the acts of
Union and he dated the take off of Great
Britain to the dismantling of the last
LAN
frontier in the 18th century he said
from from this moment Great Britain was
an island nation no soldiers no vehicle
for royal repression maybe there's
something in that but then this is the
really big one and this is the one that
struck all of these visitors as the most
anomalous the most inexplicable of all
and that is the beautiful system that we
call common law which again is very very
remarkable I mean you'd expect if you
were designing a legal system right you
would expect the system to be the way
the rest of the world operates the way
the civil Roman law systems have where
you write a law down and then you apply
it to a particular case it stands to
reason doesn't it how extraordinary and
again we are blase about the familiar
how extraordinary to have a legal system
where nobody wrote it down where the
legal corpus grew up case by case like a
coral with the judgment of each case
serving as the starting point of the
next one so that instead of being an
instrument of government control the
legal system was open to the individual
seeking redress there was an assumption
of residual rights it was taken as read
that if something were not expressly
prohibited it was allowed very very
different political climate that that
creates believe me if you worked where I
worked you would see this every day the
starting point for most of my colleagues
in the European Parliament whenever I
say why do we need an EU directive on
this is so good but it's unregulated and
in the
in the Continental mindset unregulated
is synonymous with illegal the idea that
that is the natural state of affairs
that if there was no problem you didn't
need a solution that strikes them as the
ultimate bizarre anglo-saxon paycheque
peculiarity we come across a sick one
that we're going through at the moment
is on banning various herbal remedies
and alternative medicines of various
kinds now I'm sure in this room there
will be a range of views about the
efficacy of alternative remedies right
as there is I mean as there is in the
hanan household my wife swears by them
she thinks they're brilliant and far
better than all the convention matter I
think that they are harmless placebos
but nobody can convince me that they are
bad for you right and there should be a
presumption of innocence in this as in
anything else that you you should assume
other things being equal that the
herbalist doesn't want to poison her
customers is not a particularly good
business model so hey I took this cause
up as I say not not because I'm a great
believer in alternative partly because
mrs. H is and as King Solomon says it is
better to have a dish of bitter herbs in
a house where there is love than a
stalled ox and hatred therewith and
perhaps never has the part about the
bitter herbs applied quite so literally
as as in this case but again what you
know what was the what was the reason
again all of my European colleagues
would say [ __ ] but you know these
things are being sold as medicines they
need to be regulated I've said that they
have been self-regulating since at least
the reign of Henry the eighth's in
England why what - what problem is this
a solution and of course the reality is
when you have that kind of mindset it
becomes open to the ambitions of vested
interest who was really behind the ban
on herbal remedies the big
pharmaceutical corporations who saw a
wonderful opportunity to impose
impossible compliance costs on their
smaller rivals which they could easily
assimilate themselves same people I've
noticed who have suddenly lined up
Obamacare but that's a different hair
different story I'd like to leave time
for for questions but I just want to
take to focus on the point that I began
with that we take things too easily for
granted the unique features of u.s.
democracy the term limits the states
rights the Localism budget the balanced
budget amendments the dispersal of power
these didn't happen accidentally they
are all working out of let's call it the
Jeffersonian ideal that was encoded at
the conception of the Republic we can
all find fault with the way they've
played out in practice perfection is not
of this world and you know what even
your constitution is not a perfect
document but I'll tell you something
it's a lot better than what you're doing
at the moment
so I would remind you of Hattin somnus
is a great line about the straight road
running from Runnymede to philadelphia
he went on in the same speech to say we
have no king we are our own masters if
we the people fail representative
government fails that doesn't that imply
an obligation yes you are inheritors of
an extraordinary patrimony you are heirs
to perhaps the finest constitution
designed by human intelligence but that
surely implies a duty of individual
Asian and care you need to keep fast the
freedoms that you inherited and pass
them on intact mats brilliant book which
I plagiarized finishes with Joseph
Warren medical doctor Chaput sent Paul
Revere out on his ride and and his his
plea to his countrymen he said on your
decision hang the happiness and freedom
of millions yet unborn act worthy of
yourselves don't those words apply
equally today as we see powers shifting
from the 50 states to Washington from
the elected representative to the
unelected functionary from the citizen
to the state we see a reversal of the
Jeffersonian model on which the
Constitution was based we see even a
reversal of that supremacy of the law
that had its birth on the river bank at
Runnymede
that it seems to me is a big
generational obligation for all of you
as Americans you are incredibly lucky to
have inherited what you did and you
don't get to mess it up you have to pass
it on in the same condition
that you inherited it from your parents
act worthy of yourselves
the prank gentlemen is read to question
time two things one is there a
historical figure who could be called
the author of the Magna Carter much as
we have
Jefferson getting the primary approval
for the Declaration of Independence and
the other is you might put into your
thinking the fact that in this country
the oath taken by politicians and
military is to defend the Constitution
not the state yes thank you
there isn't a single author and in fact
most of the authors were illiterate
which is why we say it was sealed rather
than signed the king like most people in
those days couldn't write
he put his his signet ring on a on a
piece of wax I think the the authors of
it created more than they knew and
perhaps more than they would have had
they known like all of these things
there is a moment in history where there
is a particular quarrel and yet
something bigger comes out of it than
anyone envisaged at the time and that
the key clause which is still on our
statute book is the one that says we the
king we may not bring people to justice
other than through due process and
according to the law of the land and
that was the really key phrase the law
of the land not the Kings law not God's
law but a law that was imminent in the
population and the territory and that
you know the idea that people sometimes
say we've romanticized it and we've made
a big thing of it later and so Magna
Carta was cited 40 times in the next two
centuries in precisely the same sense
that its authors intended ie as a
guarantee against state power the
perhaps the greatest constitutional
authority
Duras of the 20th century in Britain
Lord Denning said it is the greatest
constitutional document of all time the
ultimate guarantor of individual freedom
against the arbitrary authority of the
despot and I think that's a pretty good
way of looking at it another way of
putting it is I would say it's it's our
it's our Torah as english-speaking
peoples it's the it's the text that sets
us apart and at the same time
paradoxically the Texas speaks universal
truths to mankind and it has a it
imposes obligations on us in that sense
any Jewish Americans in the audience
lucky you you've got to you have a
religious one I'm a secular one Mazel
Tov
but for the rest of us this this one is
a pretty good a pretty good guide I
think as to as to what our role in the
world is and it worked it drove your
father's in mind to carry the vision of
freedom to our to less happy countries I
completely agree about the oath of
office and if you asked me what is the
supreme recommendation for a candidate
for political office in this country I
would say simply that he mean it when he
takes his oath of office
everything else is implied by that mr.
Hanna Greg : here Madison fellow and
here at Hillsdale and I just wanted to
give you the an opportunity on the
Scottish vote to maybe give us your
thoughts while we have you here thank
you first of all I'm very happy to live
in a country where you can do this I'm
delighted to live in a country where
people can vote freely and peacefully to
belong or not belong and there's no
question about the result being
respected that is as I understand it not
completely the case here when a state
attempts to secede from the union people
have strong views about it but it is it
is inconceivable that a shot would have
been fired in anger over the question
either way over the question of Scottish
independence and I'm happy about that
it's it's unusual that said I'm glad the
the result went as it did
the border between England and Scotland
is not ethnographic or linguistic it's
it came about through happenstance not
not through demographic reality there's
no obvious differences of what we would
normally take as defining
characteristics of nationality on the
two sides of the border it's it's not
like between the UK and France or you
know we speak the same language we
abused alcohol in the same way we have
the same problems with you know obesity
and teenage pregnancies we sing the same
songs we watch the same TV program you
know we follow the same sports shop at
the same stores so where did the desire
for a breakaway come from it basically
came from an element of the far left in
Scotland who have become very dominant
there for reasons which require a whole
separate lecture who was saying if you
vote for us they'll never be another
Conservative government well in the
short term at least that would have been
true but is that really the way you want
to launch a new country you know the the
defining ethic of the new countries that
it's going to spend more and borrow more
and tax more I'm not sure that that
would have been a grave success I'm
happy you know somebody who is mainly
ethnically Scottish I'm very happy the
Scotland has decided to reaffirm its
place in the Anglo sphere and in the
United Kingdom the EU referendum is very
close we could have a vote as early as
two years from now and polls are finally
balanced the Scottish independence
campaign moved from 20 points behind to
10 points behind during the campaign we
are starting from level pegging so I
think it is a winnable one and in that
one I will be strongly campaigning to
take Britain out of the European Union
and to rejoin the wider family of free
english-speaking democracies who have
been our truest friends down the ages
the European Union has left us poorer
less democratic and less free and I
guarantee if any of you in this room
were living in the European Union you
would be Euroskeptics you in fact you
would realize what a limited and minor
problem you have with
excessive central government here if you
had to spend a couple of days where I
work I see the great John Fontaine
nodding along who is one of the
Americans who totally gets what is so
awful about the EU project if I can make
a slightly cheeky plea it may well be
the case when the referendum comes that
people come asking us politicians for as
they as Obama has done for defenses of
the status quo
okay the current president was very
happy to say you shouldn't leave unless
there's a bigger problem okay
frankly that doesn't matter so much but
if a Republican president were to say
the same thing I think it would be a
real blow to the no campaign because
people would say to us look even your
friends even the people that you're
closest to the ones that you look up
even they have told us to stay where we
are so any of you who have any influence
with the wider conservative movement and
I can see a few people in the audience
who do it would be very helpful if when
the time comes you were simply to say in
or outside the EU will have a good
strong friendly relationship and
alliance with United Kingdom that's all
we need you know all we need is
neutrality leave the rest to us
Oh
so I go first yes yeah thank you what is
the relationship between the magna carta
and holy scriptures or natural law
well the of course it's signed by
bishops and it begins with an
imprecation of their deity as as all
documents in that time dead but what I
think is hugely significant is the idea
that you've moved the legal system into
the secular field you've got the concept
that the law is a folk right that it
belongs to the people that it isn't
interpreted by an Episcopal sea or by an
imam or by a religious authority in
other words you've moved away from what
could have otherwise been an arbitrary
interpretation which i think is hugely
significant now I suspect that almost
all of the signatories just given the
time it was signed would have been
Christians and you know it at least
would have called themselves Christians
so they would have no doubt being
imperfect or in fact some of them were
very imperfect Christie was not least
King John who was a terrible human being
but but the significance which I think
is hugely important now when we look at
competing claims of religious and
secular law in less happy parts of the
world than now the idea that you could
be a devout and observant believer and
yet believed in a separate legal system
that was non ecclesiastical I think is a
vital foundation of a free society
karlof Gallivan truth is beauty beauty
is truth the Constitution recognizes
gold and silver coin as money as did the
Bretton Woods agreements do you foresee
that a restoration of the Bretton Woods
Agreement where we we restore an honest
unit of account internationally would be
beneficial and secondly regarding the
Magna Carta contemporaneous with its
signing the Pope of Rome declared that
no one void forever and I don't believe
has ever recanted from that position is
that still relevant in history you know
to be honest it probably was it accorded
with the patriotic pride of some
Victorian historians that this had been
a kind of something done into faience of
the Vatican I don't think it does
anymore no I think the Catholic Church
of today is not the medieval papacy
we've all moved on and I think we all
accept the the values of it but on the
on what I think is really a very very
interesting point about a commodity
based currency I'm astonished by how far
this argument has moved in the last five
years particularly in this country what
was an absolutely fringe position has
suddenly become something that everybody
at least needs to address hasn't yet
become a mainstream
view but it's it's no longer something
that you don't discuss in polite society
and I think the reason that this has
happened is not because of the
persuasiveness of its advocates although
that plays a measure in it but some of
the advocates of this position are not
particularly persuasive some of them
show aspects of behaving like a cult I
remember as a student the kind of people
who banged on about the gold not they
how can I put this eight they didn't
seem interested in building a broad
consensus beyond the people who already
agreed with them what's really changed
is the financial crisis and the response
by governments to it and that made a lot
of people think oh hang on maybe those
guys who were banging on about Austrian
economics and gold 20 maybe they weren't
this is what they said would
and maybe we should take another look
and you know where she do a plea to
quote Keynes the guy who has been
discredited by it when he said you know
he said that when the facts change I
changed my mind what do you do sir
the facts it seems to me changed
massively with the financial crash it
was clear that central banks had failed
that they had kept interest rates too
low for too long that they had stoked a
boom that they'd encouraged man
investment and the response when the
crash came was more of the same cut
interest rates even further print more
money
that's what's vindicated the gold and
silver all the commodities based
currency position and yes I think it
will I think it will happen sooner the
you know the place I'm watching Iceland
because Iceland basically is in it is
having a great debate about what to do
with its currency it it is the the
smallest population in the world to have
its own currency if I can put it that
way it's not the smallest territory on
earth but all the others are in a
currency union with with a neighbor it's
the it's the smallest it's the currency
backed by the smallest number of people
and it suffered very badly as a result
of this when the financial crisis came
in there's now a huge debate should they
adopt the Canadian dollar should they
drop the Norwegian crown should they've
got the pound should they dove the Euro
or why not become a commodity back
currency and it won't be rather
brilliant about this is of course they
they don't have very much gold having
been through what they've just been
through they don't sit on gold mines but
the great commodity they have is fish so
we would have what they originally had
in Iceland with the very early settlers
we would have a commodity backed
currency based on quotas of fish doesn't
really matter what the commodity is as
long as it's outside of the control of
the government right as long as
governments can't abuse it through
inflation doesn't matter what it is and
I think that's the that's the
fascinating one to watch there is a
right-of-center coalition in Iceland
they've had presentations by every kind
of groups of economists all competing
that's the that's going to be the the
the laboratory
yeah yeah I mean wait you know we're
still at an early stage of course of the
of the completely free currencies and
whereas five years ago you could have
said what are you worried about right
the end of Bretton Woods has led has
gone hand in hand with unprecedented
prosperity for the whole world that is a
much shaky argument to make now
it's always wonderful when Daniel Hannan
comes through town here to the States
he's a wonderful speaker and a great
scholar he also reminds us of great
friendships with our english-speaking
relatives friend of mine for 'nope
Hillsdale College they also remind us
what happens to countries which don't
have written constitutions and become to
be administered by other countries which
reminds us we have things good here and
I thank you for that you're always
welcome until Zell you here on the home
campus and I look forward to your visits
and of course I have a Hillsdale tie to
wear to your next location and you're in
your next talk and I thank all of you
for coming today thank you very much